Elite female cyclists racing through the
Essex Countryside on a day when hoot can
compete in female races was restricted
to those born female by British cycling
their boss announcing a new open
category for anyone identifying as
non-binary or assigned male at Birth
it's very difficult it's divisive it's
emotive is affecting human beings the
science isn't certain so why go against
inclusivity we want to give direction we
want to remove the uncertainty and
certainly the athletes have been
affected by this uncertainty created
over the past few months I'm really
sorry for the anxiety for the upset
transgender women had been able to race
in women's events if their testosterone
was below a particular level but that
policy was suspended 14 months ago amid
a backlash
this transgender cyclist had won races
competing as a male while transitioning
she was blocked from her potential debut
in a women's event and now Emily Bridges
feels banned calling British cycling a
failed organization
she called the new policy a violent act
adding I don't even know if I want to
race my bike anymore the danger and
everything that would come with racing
makes it a pretty hard thing to justify
to myself
Emily and a number of athletes are
clearly affected by this policy but what
we wanted to provide at this point in
time is The Clarity on the direction of
travel Clarity welcome by female Riders
who did not want to compete against
anyone with potential benefits of male
puberty
sport we're talking about
a meal advancement
otherwise you are discriminating against
women and girls but sport can seem to be
discriminating against those already
facing discrimination in wider Society
having an open category trans women are
not men and it's really taking away what
the future is for our young people
involved in sports as well and we're not
actually seeing conversations around the
research we're not seeing conversations
around being more inclusion but
exclusion is also the policy of
Athletics and Aquatics globally now
International cycling Chiefs have to
decide whether to follow Britain by
prioritizing sporting fairness over
inclusivity Rob Harris Sky News